&gt;&gt; Vertical and horizontal lines are somewhat tricky. They go against our
intuition. When we think of vertical lines, we usually think about the variable
y. But the equation is actually x equals. It's because the x-coordinate for
every point on this line was 2. When we usually think about the horizontal
direction, we think about the variable x. But horizontal lines are always in the
form, y equals. All the points on this line have a y-coordinate of negative 3,
that's why it's y equals. When math goes against our intuition, it's helpful to
stop and think, what's true for all the points? What is this line really saying?
The coordinates of each point can be a lot of information, and they help us find
the equations of the lines.